[Music]
I mean and Ximénez with these people I
mean
[Music]
the ing
in the navy software is that there is
no wind
ah
[Music]
huitlacoche's shoulder might
be weird but here in mexico it's very
tasty and a lot of people  he eats it
my name is nicolás aguilar martínez
i'm on the streets of niza and liverpool
mexico city huitlacoche is
the corn fungus and it's a gray colored granite
that is very soft some say it
tastes like dirt hot for me it's the gel of
the  Tender themes I usually make them
in quesadillas
I prepare this one the onion the chili and then
the huitlacoche since it is in a vaporcito
I added everything that is this the epazote
with the with the salt I make the tortilla and
I put the cheese and I put it in the
iron the huitlacoche is in mexican
with a taco al pastor not so popular
but it is tasty more than the meat
remembering that the internal resignation
operation
anna wintour y locos
[Music]
the word dor y locos comes from combining
doritos with locos is a p  latillo that
we mexicans invented
my name is sana juana pacheco brown I
work at elotes Esquites Anthropology Museum it
is located on Paseo de
la Reforma and Mexico City it
is the carrot girl more cucumbers
skinny peanuts gummies pajín love and
sauce you
could say it is a snack  because it
's like a kind of junk food
you could say it's magical because you do
n't know any other one
transmitting no other food it's
unique
[Music
] safe
[Music]
the minister city seafood market
is the second largest
worldwide after tokyo my name
is tamaris i am the owner of
seafood restaurant caguamo we are above the
town hall and lopez in mexico city
here in this business we sell seafood from
veracruzano style our specialty is
octopus ceviche we start with the
octopus so add some
seasonings and put it in  to cook that
having the octopus cooked at its point we
add some vegetables and sauces
I'll sell it to you on toast with
octopus ceviche on top of cilantro, onion and
avocado
here you don't get much out of sharing
our food from Veracruz with everyone
from Mexico City
in Eibar dromo the wall street
month picas de puertos and activists in the
district traditionally it's the
chilaquiles are served on a plate but
we decided to put them in the
bolillo my name is pearl we are in
the streets of alfonso reyes and tamaulipas
in mexico city i dressed as aquiles
with salsa with a golden tortilla for
20 years as the first to put
chilaquiles in  the cake je we did not
invent the chili cake here it has
beans a milanese the chilaquil can
be green or red that if cream and the
bolillo is a flavor that I could not
describe it to you it is delicious because this
is a family business they are more  four
generations
how to count calories to our land to
our land but with this to say not to
take as many calories because if
everything takes calories  it can be a little something three
runs from the casualties
[Music]
dawn our former saunier from baseball game
with an der vaart believe in the heart
take on brings me with this maxi construction tradition
[Music]
I love to cook today he learned to be
the tlacoyos to the  7 years my name is
pan and the establishment is called ojitos
mexicanas red and we are located
here in gonzález obregón here in
mexico city one of our
specialties here in
mexico city is the skinny one I first stick
to the amount of dough  you put the
filling that can be beans or cottage cheese
it is closed it is made like a catholic I have
7 kos at a certain time it is taken out
again to drink it is prepared with
nopales onion grated cheese and the sauce
that can be green or red
a very exquisite flavor  like when you
eat a piece of paper and you can't eat
just one
month anyway the tag on guard also in
francisco solís is wanting filters
n from youtube com/watch wire los
bonitos de nortea  mérica
lettuce let them rice ingredients that
we do not put in our burritos my
name is francisco javier solís we are
on liverpool street between
niza street and it opens in mexico city
we specialize in a burrito
called pumpkin flower that  bonito
contains onion, tomato, squash blossoms,
a little bit of beans and what it is, and
we finish it off with a termite of cheese
that we call stylish,
the flavor is natural, tasty, consistency
very, very rich in Mexico, if it is difficult to
find vegetarian food in Mexico,
I know that  they make another
squash flower burrito I don't want to think about it and
we institute it we create it following this
because the nests of risks are always
taken and this rhythm of making the
vegetarian world plays nice for many
[Music]